-Hey, Alison, it's Bread Week.
-I know.
Which gives us the perfect chance
to promote our brand-new album,
Alison and Noel's
Bake It Till You Make It.
Side one's a cracker.
"Is There Loaf on Mars?"
"Crumb Together", "Yeast of Burden".
Plus, "Dough Your Own Way", "Purple Grain"
and "You Knead Me, I Don't Knead You"
by Bread Sheeran.
So that's Alison and Noel's
Bake It Till You Make It.
Coming soon.
Available in all good bakeries.
[both] Welcome to
The Great British Baking Show.
Now we need someone to promote this.
-Don't you know Stormzy?
-Yeah, I was in his video.
-Don't rub it in.
-Should I text or call him?
You've got his number?
I tried to get his number. He said,
"Get lost, goblin. I'll call the police."
-[Alison] This week…
-[gasps]
…the bakers battle…
-Blue eyes at 11 o'clock.
-…on Hollywood's home turf.
Oh. Oh, dear.
With a savoury signature…
That's called a perfect dough!
…a tangled technical…
Oh! Oh, I hate Bread Week.
…and a super-sized showstopper.
It's so big and the colour's amazing.
[Alison] Who will crack
under the pressure?
I've gotta rush.
[Alison] And who will rise
to the occasion?
Just wait.
My time is coming.
[opening theme music playing]
[intriguing music playing]
[indistinct chatter]
I am back for another week,
standing straight.
[laughs]
Yeah, I'm ready. Bread Week, let's go.
Bread Week! [screams]
-[Andy sighs]
-Let's go.
[Andy] I'm looking forward to it.
At the same time,
I'm not a professional,
I'm just an amateur mechanic.
Well, not an amateur mechanic. [laughs]
I am qualified fully.
Done me apprenticeship.
But I haven't done it in breadmaking.
Welcome back to the tent, bakers,
for your first challenge of Bread Week.
Now, the judges would love you
to make a batch of 12 tasty, savoury buns.
This is one of the few workplaces
where you can compliment someone's buns.
Without getting a visit from HR.
-[Alison] Exactly.
-How are your buns, Alison?
-They're juicy, babes.
-[laughter]
Your buns need to be made
from yeasted dough.
[Alison] But the shape
and the style is up to you.
I'm actually looking forward
to seeing some unusually shaped buns.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake!
[amusing music playing]
I do like baking bread,
but I like baking bread for myself
and my friends, not Paul Hollywood.
No pressure.
-[Georgie] Oh, gosh! [sniffles]
-[Paul] It's Bread Week.
We want the bakers to produce
12 identical savoury buns.
We're testing the bakers' knowledge
on basic breadmaking,
so we want to see a good structure,
a nice stretchy dough and a great flavour.
[Andy] When making bread,
you need to show that love.
But also, at the same time,
you need to show the bread who's boss.
The nice thing about this bunch of bakers
is that they are so imaginative.
But I think what I'd like
is something original,
something I've never tasted.
But, ultimately,
it's got to be good bread.
[bees buzzing]
-Hi, Andy.
-Hello, Paul.
-Hello, Andy.
-How are we?
[Prue] More important, how are you?
Yeah, not so bad. Mustn't grumble.
-[laughs]
-This is going a bit--
Tell us about your buns.
The inspiration behind this
is my daughter.
Once upon a time I was making bread,
I was looking for chorizo.
I didn't have any,
so I was raiding through,
and one of her favourite
little salami treats was looking at me,
and I thought, "Happy days, I'll use 'em."
[Noel] Maisie's chopped salami sticks
will be folded into Andy's dough
along with cheddar cheese and chives.
I like the idea of the flavours.
It's about the texture on the bread
and getting the flavour in every bite,
which is the key.
What size are these buns?
They based on Paul's buns?
He's got lovely buns.
[laughter]
You said that like you knew,
you'd been going out five years.
[Andy laughs, mumbles]
[Noel] Whilst Andy has raided
his daughter's lunchbox…
It's very close to my heart,
these flavours,
and I'll be thinking of Maisie today
whilst doing them,
and I'll miss her so much.
[Alison] …Illiyin has taken a leaf
out of Mum's recipe book.
[Illiyin] I am making a Jamaican coco bun.
My mum used to make this.
It's like an enriched dough
made with coconut milk.
It's not exactly good for the waistline,
but great for joy.
[laughs]
[Alison] Illiyin's coco buns will be
filled with Jamaican brown stew chicken
and topped with spiced
crispy chicken skin.
-How are you feeling?
-Fine.
-Are you all right?
-Much better.
You had me worried.
You were on the floor for ages.
-I know!
-I was like, "Please come back."
-I'm so glad you're better.
-I'm good.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Feel good?
-Strong?
-Ready to go.
-Okay.
-[chuckles]
Is that kneaded enough?
[sighs] I don't know.
[Noel] It's crucial that the dough
is sufficiently kneaded
if the gluten proteins
are to bond together,
creating a strong elastic structure.
[Dylan] That's perfect.
So you can stretch it really thin
and see the light through it
and it won't tear.
So that's exactly like what you want.
[Noel] Once the bakers are happy
with their dough…
-[Nelly] Done!
-…they can start the first of two proves.
Let's get that in.
The first prove develops
that gluten and stuff
and gets you your flavours coming in,
you know?
I just hope it proves.
If it doesn't, it won't be as light
and fluffy as I'd like it to be.
If anyone's gonna pick up on it,
it's gonna be the Breadfather.
-Morning, Dylan.
-Morning, Paul.
-Hello, Dylan.
-Morning, Prue. Morning, Noel.
Tell us about what you're doing.
The dough is filled with gochujang,
which is a Korean fermented chilli paste.
-It's a very pungent chilli paste.
-It is punchy.
Yeah, that gives the dough
a nice orange colour.
[Noel] What does Hollywood think?
-Interesting.
-[chuckles]
[Noel] As well as
his fermented chilli paste,
Dylan will run confit of garlic
throughout the dough of his buns,
which, although simple,
he is hoping will prove
he has what it takes
to forge a career in the kitchen.
-I wanna be a chef.
-Do you?
Yeah.
[softly] Chefs… Chefs are always ugly.
-Chefs are always ugly?
-Yeah. You're too handsome.
-Have you seen Gordon Ramsay?
-[laughs loudly]
-He's like an omelette with human eyes.
-[cackling]
Don't put that in the show,
he'll beat me up.
I am scared of Gordon Ramsay.
Actually, he's got
a sort of devil-may-care pirate
sort of sexiness about him.
[Alison] Whilst the dough is proving…
Smells so nice everywhere. Mm! Yeah.
…focus turns to fillings.
[Gill] ♪ Bacon, bacon, bacon
Crispy, crispy bacon ♪
[laughs]
So I'm making an oregano pesto
inspired by lots of holidays to Greece.
Oh, I love Kefalonia,
the food, the people.
It's just… the sun.
[Alison] John is hoping his pesto,
red onion and feta-stuffed buns
will be enough to impress Paul today.
He's gonna be prodding, tearing.
-Oh, yeah.
-Who does that?
-Just get rid of Paul.
-You and Noel can judge.
-It will be all right.
Everyone would win. No one will go home.
-That's exactly what we want.
-Especially not you.
You're going nowhere.
-Sumayah, morning.
-Morning.
Morning, Sumayah.
Tell us all about your savoury buns.
What are you doing?
So they're gonna be a milk bread
stuffed with a spiced chicken filling,
and I'm gonna shape them
to look like sunflowers.
[Noel] Sumayah's sunflowers will be glazed
with a yellow turmeric oil
and filled
with a Bangladeshi chicken curry.
So how did you feel
about being Star Baker last week?
It was a shock.
Like, I was not expecting it at all.
You might do it again this week,
you never know.
-[Sumayah laughs] I don't think so.
-[Noel] Good luck.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-[Sumayah] Thank you.
[Noel] The reigning Star Baker's curry…
Oh, that's good. Spicy, though. Whoo!
…has competition.
I'm coming from Slovakia from Europe,
my husband's Asian, Pakistani.
We have different cultures,
so we kind of mix it.
So the filling is very Pakistani
and the dough is Slovakian,
so we are the perfect match.
[Noel] Nelly's celebration of her marriage
will see her Slovakian milk bread
filled with husband Chand's
favourite veggie curry,
before being rolled
and cut into triangles.
-Triangles?
-[Nelly] Yes.
You roll whole pastry, you fill it in.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-Roll it.
-Then you cut in triangles.
-On an angle.
Are you using egg wash on top?
Yes, and a little bit sesame seed
just to make it a bit pretty.
If there's egg wash left,
can you use it on Paul's cheeks?
But he's already shiny.
-That's a compliment.
-I look shiny?
Yeah, you know…
You look beautiful the way you are.
-[laughs]
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
Good luck.
They don't trust me.
They do not trust my triangles, do they?
Just wait.
My time is coming.
[Alison] Nelly's not the only baker
experimenting with fusion flavours.
[Mike] So this lamb
is from our farm at home.
And then I'm adding soya sauce,
cumin, five spice.
My partner and I,
we love Asian fusion food,
so it just reminds me of Matt.
So, yeah, he is here with me and my buns.
[chuckles]
[Alison] Mike's Baaa-o buns
will be a clash of Asian spices
and traditional Sunday roast flavours.
Is lavender going in it?
-That's rosemary.
-[both laugh]
[laughs]
[Alison] Let's do that again.
No one'll know.
Is rosemary going in this as well?
Yes, rosemary in the minced meat.
Rosemary and mint from the garden.
Were you impressed
I knew this was rosemary?
I was so impressed.
I saw that and thought, "Is it lavender?"
-Did you?
-Yeah.
I don't know what made you think that.
That's weird.
I'm such an idiot.
I'm making my mustard drizzle,
which is also known as mustard custard.
You just like saying "mustard custard".
I do love saying that.
-We all like saying "mustard custard".
-[both laughing]
I feel like that's gonna go viral.
Can't believe I'm 50 and I've said
it's gonna go viral. That's sad.
[Noel] Gill's tangy mustard custard
will be drizzled over the top
of her black pudding,
chorizo and goat's cheese
savoury Chelsea buns.
You've got an amazing amount of filling.
-How much bread are you making?
-[Paul] What's your dough weight?
I've got 600 grammes of flour.
-How much water?
-360 mil.
-So you've got a kilo of dough.
-Yeah.
And how much do all these weigh?
-So there's about 600 grammes there.
-Yeah.
There's to be 200 grammes of that
and about 200 grammes of that.
One to one?
Northern portions, Paul.
Northern portions.
[laughter]
[Alison] Whilst Gill is serving up
a generous taste of the north…
-[John] Is that all black pudding?
-Don't you start!
[both laugh]
It's not for me.
…Georgie is packing her Chelsea buns
with the flavours of Italy.
So this is my pesto.
So in here there is wild garlic, basil,
pine nuts and Parmesan cheese,
and normal garlic as well,
so it's like, ah!
[Alison] Alongside
her garlic-packed pesto,
Georgie will fill
her Chelsea bun-style rolls
with sundried tomatoes and mozzarella.
Is Bread Week a good week for you?
It's definitely positive for me.
I make bread at home.
-Just a standard batch loaf every week.
-Yeah.
But I think compared to Biscuit Week,
this is definitely more my week.
-Don't think about Biscuit Week.
-[both] That's gone.
Nowhere to be seen.
-Bye.
-Goodbye.
[birds chirping]
-You look great today.
-Aw, thanks.
-Wearing one of Prue's dresses?
-Can you tell?
-It's lovely. I'm wearing Paul's pants.
-[both laugh]
Just do "halfway through".
Bakers, you are halfway through!
-[Alison] With the first prove complete…
-That's called a perfect dough!
It's doubled in size, so let's go for it.
…the bakers now face a race
to fill and shape their rolls…
-I think you've done that before.
-[laughs]
-That's brilliant.
-I have done it a couple of times.
[chuckles] Never under
that much pressure though.
[Alison] …if they're to maximise
the all-important second prove.
It should expand and get the fluffiness
and lightness from the second prove.
Paul's gonna watch this back and go,
"What the hell is she talking about?"
Blue eyes at 11 o'clock. [chuckles]
Oh. Oh, dear.
[Mike laughs]
[Noel] But introducing warm
or wet fillings into delicate dough…
[Illiyin] Make sure
there's not too much liquid.
Got a good bit of chicken.
Exactly how it should be.
…can be problematic
if the filling is sealed inside.
[John] There's additional moisture
and steam in the rolls
'cause there's oil in the pesto,
but it gives it a bit of lift as well.
So I don't know if it's a good
or bad thing, to be honest.
It always works at home.
Let's just hope it works here.
Famous last words in the tent.
[Noel] While some are taking a chance
on a moist middle,
others have opted
to release the liquid in style.
So I'm just cutting eight little slits
into each bun to create the flower shape.
You can see the filling when it bakes,
so I think that's quite nice.
[Christiaan] I've put the fillings in,
and now I'm doing my four-strand plaits.
It's not too difficult,
but you need to get into the rhythm.
So I've got like a little like…
you swing with the strands.
Right side to the inside, left side,
right side, left side, right side.
And you're done. You need to get
into the swing of it. [laughs]
[Noel] Christiaan's knotted plaits
will be made up
of an infused mushroom dough,
hazelnut, sage and truffle oil pesto,
and, for an extra umami kick,
some porcini mushrooms.
The only thing that worries me
is you've got porcini and truffle.
-Yeah.
-I've never put the two together.
I love mushroom, like…
Never enough mushrooms.
You're a "fungi".
[laughs] Basically.
[Alison] With the bakers' buns
now weighed down with fillings…
Looking good so far.
…holding their nerve
during the second prove is crucial.
It is a waiting game with bread.
Normally, I'd go down the shops
or just go and do something.
[Alison] But every moment spent proving
is a moment lost to baking.
-[Alison] I was wondering about the hats.
-What?
I was thinking about it all last night.
I was thinking, have you been…
[Andy] Hmm?
…confident enough to bring ten hats?
Yeah, no.
-So how many hats have you got?
-Three. [laughs]
-So this is the last one?
-This is an omen, innit?
Do I take them out
and baste them and start baking?
[Georgie] I'm like,
"Do I pull 'em out of the prove?"
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
-Yeah, I am going to…
-Yeah, I am.
[both laugh]
[Gill] They're touching, so that's good.
[Dylan] So if I push this,
it'll come back, but just halfway.
That means my bread is now proved,
so I'll score it and then pop it in.
[Noel] Scoring the buns encourages them
to open up in the oven,
producing a scar-like crust
known as an ear.
I'm hoping to get a nice ear on my bread.
I really, really want these to be good.
If they're not, I'll be really upset.
That's gonna go straight in now.
I think they look good.
I just hope they bake okay.
[Noel] As the buns hit
the heat of the oven…
We shall see if it's gonna work or not.
If it doesn't, I know where is the exit.
…the bakers face an anxious wait…
[sighs heavily]
Come on, darlings, do your thing.
…to see if all their kneading
and proving has paid off.
You say you won't do the Bake Off thing
and sit by the oven.
But there's nothing else to do.
My bread is so simple.
So, I'm really hoping this is good bread.
[inhales sharply] Hopefully.
-Hello, Gill.
-Hello.
-Are you just loitering about?
-The calm before the storm.
They're in, just need them to bake now.
-Are you using pig's blood?
-Yes, I am.
-Nice.
-Does that meet with your approval?
-Human blood would be better.
-Better?
Isn't pig's blood
the closest to human blood?
-Yes.
-[laughs]
[hisses]
Oh, stop it. I'm salivating.
Bakers, you've got five minutes left!
[Andy] Give 'em another little glaze,
get a nice bit of shine and colour on 'em.
[Dylan] Why are they all so pale?
Could be the cuts aren't deep enough,
but they still taste great.
Well, I think they do.
Pray that they're just really soft.
The best buns he's ever gonna
sink his teeth into. [laughs]
[Illiyin] This is not a traditional bread.
It's like such a flaky outside.
I think Paul might be like,
"Where's the bread?"
I hope the fillings makes him go,
"Don't worry about it, babes."
[chuckles]
Bakers, you have one minute left!
[Georgie] Mine are coming out.
[Noel exclaims]
It's like I collided with a genie.
[gasps] They are the most beautiful buns
I've ever seen.
[Nelly] That's how they should look.
Some have an ear,
but other ones just look like a mess.
That's so annoying.
These are bottom shelf ones.
You can tell they expanded a bit more.
They look really fluffy. But I don't know,
I feel like they might be underbaked.
[John] Couple have split,
but I'd rather them be filled properly.
I'll put a bit of gold leaf on top.
Here we go. Don't need gravy
when you've got mustard custard.
I've gotta rush.
Trying to rotate them all
so it minimises how bad they look.
Bakers, that's it. Your time is up.
[sighs]
Please step away from your buns.
-[all cheering]
-[Georgie] Well done, guys.
-Well done.
-Yours look absolutely beautiful.
I hope they're not underbaked.
Oh, look at him,
posh man with gold leaf on top.
[all laughing]
[birds chirping]
[Alison] The bakers' savoury buns
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Hi, Georgie.
-Hi.
-Hi, Georgie.
[tense classical music playing]
-I love the look. They look appetising.
-[Prue] They do.
These are garlic, pesto,
sundried tomato and mozzarella.
-[Prue] Crumb looks lovely, doesn't it?
-[Paul] Mmm.
[sighs]
[Prue] I think it's delicious.
Classic flavours.
But they're nice and punchy,
and there's enough of them.
[Paul] It needed more Parmesan.
So close, erm…
I would have given a handshake for that.
-Oh, gosh.
-Just not quite there,
but that's one of the nicest
Chelsea buns we had for a while.
Should she have grated it on the top?
-That what you wanted?
-[Paul] Yeah.
That's what she's been marked down for?
-She hasn't been marked down.
-Okay.
-[Georgie chuckling]
-Tell you what I'll do, give you a pat.
-Pat. Oh, I'll take that!
-[all cheer and laugh]
-Well done.
-Thank you so much.
[laughs] The first-ever Hollywood pat.
-[laughs]
-You've just made history.
[classical music playing]
I'm a bit nervous of this
because when I saw your pan,
it seemed to have a huge amount
of chilli in it.
[quirky classical music playing]
[Paul] It's got a lovely flavour.
Spice level's perfect. The chicken's good.
-The heat's not super strong, it's nice.
-[Prue] It's perfect.
I like the crispy chicken skin as well.
It's got a lovely blend of textures
that adds to the bread.
-Yeah, nice. Like them.
-Thank you.
[quaint classical music playing]
[Paul] Great-looking roll.
The spiral is effective.
They are filled with lamb,
onions and carrots,
spiced with cumin, five spice,
and then some rosemary and some mint.
That lamb is delicious.
-Oh.
-The bread's a little bit tight,
but it sort of works
because it's very short.
With the filling, it's delicious.
I'm slightly disappointed in the filling.
I agree that it's delicious,
but I'm getting more cumin than lamb.
Yeah.
-[Paul] They look quite nice.
-[Prue] Nice and shiny.
So it is a oregano dough
with an oregano and garlic pesto,
caramelised red onion
and barrel-aged feta.
-[Paul] Oh, dear. [chuckles]
-That's not good.
Anything that's in there
that's got liquid in it,
as it bakes, it produces steam,
-and then the steam creates the pocket.
-Uh-huh.
[Prue] I actually like the flavour.
-I just think the textures aren't perfect.
-[John] Yeah.
-[Paul] Mmm. It's a bit dry.
-[Prue] Mmm.
I think it's golden just like you.
-Thanks, bab.
-[laughter]
-Good job. Thank you.
-Thanks, John.
[Prue] Look at that.
-You must be pleased with that.
-Yeah.
I could just sit here
and eat this all afternoon.
-Really?
-It is a very, very soft roll.
It's got a nice flavour, well-balanced.
-I think it's decent. Well done.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Like the look of them. I do.
They're filled with black pudding,
chorizo, goat's cheese,
have mustard custard on the top,
and bacon crumbles.
[Paul] Love the flavours.
Chorizo works beautifully well
with the black pudding.
The mustard gives it a nice, light feel
and another element to the flavour.
It's all blended together.
And I love the texture of the bread.
-It's quite soft.
-[Paul] Mmm. It's very soft.
-Thank you.
-I think it's original, delicious,
-and witty.
-[Gill] Thank you.
[Paul] Thank you, Gill.
[quaint classical music playing]
These are chicken milk buns
inspired by sunflowers.
-You've certainly got the irregular look.
-Yeah. [laughs]
[Paul] Erm…
the variety of different shades.
-And they have split slightly in places.
-Mmm.
-Let's have a look.
-[Prue] They look really beautiful.
-[Sumayah] Thank you.
-Very original and delicious-looking.
Sumayah, the filling is
absolutely delicious. It's a little dry.
-I also think it's under-proved.
-Okay.
-A bit dense.
-Yeah.
But I love the flavour of the curry.
The filling is exceptional.
-Thank you, Sumayah.
-Thank you.
[Paul] I like the shape,
like a pizza slice.
Yeah. It's kind of like
a sweeter, well, milky bun
with curry inside
with coriander and chilli chutney.
Mmm, quite interesting, because it feels
as if it would be quite heavy
because it looks dense,
but it's light in the mouth.
-[Paul] Erm…
-Oh, no.
I like it, but I was expecting
more of a punch from it.
Probably you will get it with that.
-Paul take only a little bit.
-[Alison] I noticed.
There's a kick to it. It works.
Thank you, I'm pleased you like it.
-Thank you, Nelly.
-Thank you very much.
-Delicious, Nelly.
-Thank you, Prue.
[Paul] I like the look of it.
A small one and a big one.
They're a bit odd in size,
but look quite nice.
[Prue] I think they look lovely.
[Christiaan] So I've chosen
a porcini-infused dough.
[Paul] Mmm.
Then we've got, erm, a sage,
hazelnut, truffle and cheddar pesto.
I'm amazed, Christiaan.
I did not think the pesto bits
and the mushrooms would be good together.
And I was wrong.
They go beautifully together
and you can taste both.
Thank you.
My concern was more
the level of truffle oil
compared with the porcini mushrooms.
Because you've got the liquid
from the mushrooms going into the dough,
you've also got just the right amount
of truffle oil,
so it blends really nicely together.
It's a decent roll.
-Absolutely lovely.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-We're having a lovely day.
Oh, yeah, we are? [laughs]
[Prue] They look really interesting.
I love the colour.
I really like the colour
and I really like the shape.
I wish I got a better ear.
I'm not happy with that.
[Paul] That's lovely.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-It's a really nice look to them.
-Okay.
-Let's have a look.
Still never tried this flavouring
you put in it.
-[Dylan] Gochujang.
-[Prue] It's mostly chilli?
-It's like a fermented chilli paste.
-[Paul] It's amazing.
The spice levels in that are delicious.
And I love the garlic.
It's not particularly strong,
but it's there.
What impressed me more than anything else
is that the crust that you've managed
to achieve on such an enriched dough
and the colour and the flavour
is so much in your face…
-My goodness.
-[all applaud and cheer]
[Prue laughs]
Wow.
Never had anything like it.
-Yeah?
-That's why you got the handshake.
-You could probably sell a lot of them.
-[laughs]
But they're lovely. I really like…
I haven't been surprised by a flavour
for a long time.
-Well done, Dylan.
-[chuckles] Cheers.
He looks positively staggered.
-Thank you.
-[laughs]
-Well done, mate.
-[Prue] Very good work.
I got a handshake, which is insane.
I love travelling
so I can pick up flavours.
And for it all just being acknowledged
right there,
that was wild, like really wild.
[Georgie] So I've had
the first Paul pat, so I'm…
[chuckles] I can't even speak,
I'm just so happy.
[sighing] Oh, God.
Yay!
I'm disappointed, of course,
but going into the technical,
I've got to pull it out the bag
to bring myself up there,
'cause everyone is amazing.
Everyone's bakes look incredible,
and had really good feedback.
I'm at the bottom of the pile, really.
[birds chirping]
[mysterious music playing]
[Alison] The bakers were able
to practise their buns,
but they have no idea what's in store
for them in the technical challenge.
[Dylan] What is that?
[Illiyin] Some type of demonstration,
I'm telling you.
Oh, is it going to be watch…
watch and make?
-That would be so cool, if it is.
-[Illiyin] Who's going to be doing it?
-[Dylan] It may be Paul.
-He's not even got an apron on. No way.
Welcome back, bakers.
Now your technical challenge has been set
by Dr Denim himself, Paul Hollywood.
Dr Denim would love you to make
a seven-strand plaited wreath.
[Alison] Now, this is a bit
of an unusual technical,
'cause Paul has given you no instructions
on how to shape your bread.
But he's not a complete monster.
He's gonna do a demonstration
for you instead.
I want all of you to come forward.
Come on.
-No way. That's sick.
-Not too fast. We don't want to spook him.
I've done a nine-strand,
never a seven-strand.
[Paul] Okay.
You start off with seven strands,
four on one side, three on another.
You work from the outside in.
So you're in, this now has four,
and then over to the middle,
this has four.
So it's out, in, all the way down,
until you get down to the bottom
-And then you invert it.
-Oh.
And then you work exactly the same.
Go over.
All the way down to the bottom.
And then all you do is trim off the ends.
And you want to join
the two pieces together.
A little pinch.
That's it.
[all applaud]
-Here's a handshake.
-[all laugh]
As ever, this will be judged blind.
So we'll ask our lovely judges
to leave the tent.
-Good luck.
-Off you pop.
And now you guys just have to remember
what Paul Hollywood did and recreate it
without the startling blue eyes
and the sausagey fingers.
[chuckles]
-You've got two hours and 30 minutes.
-On your marks.
Get set.
[Noel] Bake.
[whimsical music playing]
-God.
-[Christiaan] This is crazy.
So we've got the full ingredient list,
but no method.
[Gill] So it's 500 grammes
of strong bread flour,
a sachet of fast-action yeast,
salt, bit of olive oil,
and he's given us a bit of leeway
on the water.
I have done stranded,
plaited loaves before.
But with a picture in front.
I'm not too good at memory games.
I have little bit experience with plaits.
Brioche we do like this in my country.
So we can make some Slovakian style.
Paul, it was such a pleasure
seeing you plaiting a loaf.
And what's so beautiful about this
is the perfect definition.
[Paul] Yeah, you can see
each and every plait.
If the dough is too soft,
then you lose all definition in the plait.
We also asked for the hole in the middle.
You have to get the strands
a decent length.
I think the other thing that is difficult
is to know exactly when
something has proved enough.
Sometimes if you under-prove, the yeast
hasn't reached its full potential.
When it goes into the oven,
the bread expands quickly
and it's gonna rip and look terrible.
-Would you like some, Prue?
-Yeah.
Let's have a cut.
[knife scraping]
-There you go.
-Doesn't that look lovely?
This should have the light crust outside
and the slight chewiness on the inside.
God, it's gorgeous. I want to kiss it.
-[chuckles] You want to kiss the bread?
-Yeah.
-We need to talk, Prue.
-[laughs]
[bird chirping]
So now I'm just kneading my dough.
The key is just keep working it.
There's no mixer,
and I am sporting a middle age injury
from putting the wheelie bins out.
So apologies to Jenina,
my physiotherapist.
I'm getting a sweat on now,
but I wanna do well
'cause I didn't have the best morning.
The dough's ready. I'll get a bowl
and put it in the proving drawer.
I assume it's gonna be
until it doubles in size.
-[timer beeps]
-Now we wait.
I'm gonna get ready for the egg wash.
I only got given one egg.
Oh, shoot.
I've put the egg in the bloody thing.
I have to do it again.
-[Nelly] Again?
-Yeah.
Why?
The glaze… [chuckles] is the egg,
and I stuck it in it.
I did wonder why there was an egg in it.
[Dylan] I'll practice doing the plait
with the cling film.
It's a smart idea.
Did you get a handshake?
-Yeah.
-You know what happens?
He shakes your hand,
puts a microchip into it.
You'll faint
and then wake up outside his house.
[laughs]
You'll be running errands for him.
It's how he got me to do this show.
Andy's really going for that bread.
-[cheers]
-[Mike] Go, Andy, go!
-[Illiyin] Go!
-[Mike] Be tender, though.
That went out the window half an hour ago.
[laughs]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
All right, let's just do this.
It looks all right.
It's doubled in size from when I started.
[Gill] I'm splitting it
to make seven strands.
[Noel] Getting the seven strands
to the correct length…
I think it should be quite long,
the strands, not small.
…will be vital.
[Georgie] When you plait, it gets shorter.
[Noel] Too short…
The more you work it,
the more it springs back.
…once plaited and joined,
the wreaths may lose
the distinctive hole in the centre.
I've got it nice and long.
We shall see how I'm gonna plait it.
Were you watching Paul when he did this?
-[Illiyin] I'm always watching Paul.
-He did it too fast.
Those Instagram videos of cats playing
with wool, that's what it was like.
[both make whooshing sounds]
What I gathered from Paul was
we start at the halfway point,
outer one goes to the centre.
And just keep on doing it.
[Alison] But not all bakers…
-Why am I not doing this right?
-…have a good memory.
[Dylan] I've forgotten a few key details.
[Alison] And starting with the strands
in the wrong position…
I think he had them
overlapped in the middle.
Can't actually remember how he started.
[Alison] …means that
when they flip their dough…
[John] That didn't work, did it?
…any dreams of replicating
Paul's perfect plait…
It's the invert that I'm like, "Er…"
…might start to unravel.
[John] I'm having a mare.
[Georgie] It's confused me now,
upside down.
Oh! Oh, I hate Bread Week.
That just seems wrong, doesn't it?
[Christiaan] This looks like what he did?
[Dylan] Christiaan,
did yours have that bulge?
-No. I don't know if this is right.
-[Dylan] Yours is right.
Look at that. Just looks so bad.
[Andy] I have to go with this dough.
I'm gonna be too far behind.
[Mike] I'm just going to marry it together
in a happy little union of bread.
[John] Oh, it's not very neat.
Bread is not my thing.
[Nelly] I use my extra dough
to make a little plait
'cause I don't like the connection
and I wanna have that finesse.
[Alison] You're adding some extra bits.
So you've elevated it to the next level.
Because it's finesse.
One day he gonna says,
"Nelly, you did it."
-What are we gonna make with this?
-I dunno.
What about a nice moustache?
I've got already.
I just shave it, leave it.
That one now needs to prove again.
We'll start with 15. Probably take 20.
-I'll do 25 and then see.
-[timer beeping]
So I'm just trying to sort the join.
[Dylan] Oh, nicely done, Andy.
Fingers crossed really.
I'm playing catch-up with these guys.
[birds chirping]
I'm just gonna have a peep.
It's proving well.
But I think, stay in there for longer.
[Dylan] That proved so quick.
Fifteen minutes.
-Yeah, it's got a bit of a spring.
-It is rising.
I'm gonna leave it five more minutes.
Really important you prove it enough
a second time.
Otherwise it expands too much
when it goes in the oven,
and it can crack when it rises.
[Mike] Right, it's going in.
Good luck, Plaity.
-[Christiaan] I hope it puffs up more.
-How's the prove? Did you check?
I just put it in.
-How much time is left?
-[beep]
Bakers! You've got half an hour left.
I'll have to bang that up.
This'll be beg, borrow and steal on time.
That is springing back rather nicely,
so egg wash time.
I'm just annoyed with the shape of mine.
It's lost the plait there.
-Okay, shove it in.
-[Nelly] Let's do this.
[Sumayah] Now we just wait.
Peekaboo.
Ooh!
[Georgie] How's he doing that?
Andy, Georgie just said,
"How's he doing that?"
[all laugh]
Magic man, me, I tell you. [laughs]
-It's in the oven?
-Mm.
[Nelly] It's proved well.
Considering it could've been
a hell of a lot worse.
Bakers, you've got ten minutes left.
[Christiaan] I think I'm coming out.
Just looks a mess. I don't know how crusty
they wanted the outside.
Just wanna give it another glaze.
Bit of shine, something to elevate it.
It's looking okay,
but I'm gonna give it a little bit longer.
I'd rather it be fully baked
than underbaked.
It looks all right,
but it lost definition.
Bakers, you've got five minutes left.
-[sighs]
-[Nelly] We are going out.
They always says lift it up
and knock on the bottom.
It's dull. Should be done.
I have no clue
what I'm meant to be listening for.
Gill, how have you got your egg wash
so beautiful?
That was precision egg washing, that.
-You've got a nice wreath.
-Don't touch it.
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
-I'm going.
[tense music playing]
It's moulded into one,
but it's a wreath, 'cause there's a hole.
My plait isn't the best,
but it's got a glaze, it's shiny.
It's nice round here, then it loses a bit.
But to be honest, compared to how it was…
Bakers, your time is up.
[chuckles] Get off the paper.
Please bring your wreaths up
and place them behind your photos.
[tense music playing]
[Dylan] I dunno why I thought
that was right. It's not even round.
Nelly, yours is amazing.
[Nelly] Thank you.
I would like him to say it's tidy.
That would make me really happy.
[birds chirping]
[Noel] It's time to judge the bakers'
seven-strand plaited wreaths.
[Prue] I'm impressed.
-He might not be, but I'm impressed.
-[all laugh]
[Noel] Paul and Prue are looking
for clearly defined plaits,
a hole in the centre,
a smooth glazed crust
and a beautifully even crumb.
And they have no idea whose is whose.
We'll start with this one.
One of the criteria we're looking for
is a hole in the middle.
It's just one big,
fancy-looking cottage loaf.
-It's got a shine, though.
-[Prue] It's a good colour.
-A bit tight inside.
-Not proved enough.
Yes. But it's baked.
This one's not too bad.
It's got good glaze
and a hole in the middle.
It lost its way a bit here.
When you roll out these strands,
sometimes if they're not even,
you get irregular shapes.
-But that's well baked.
-[Prue] Yeah, it's lighter.
It's springy, but it's not so resistant.
[Paul] This one's lost its way.
There's just no definition in it at all.
-But the bake's okay.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-I think that's nice bread.
-Mmm.
Moving on to this, again,
has lost some of the definition,
-and it's a bit soft.
-[Prue] And a bit pale.
-Mmm.
-[Paul] It tastes okay.
It wasn't proved enough.
I don't think it's too bad, this.
It's a nice, strong colour.
It feels lighter.
-But the plait lost its way a bit.
-[Prue] It's a little uneven.
-Bake in it's pretty good.
-[Prue] Mmm.
-Nice texture, isn't it?
-Mmm.
Okay, moving on to this one.
The plait is not bad.
This is a nice-looking loaf.
It's nice and soft.
That's decent.
I like this. Someone's plaited before.
-It's got a plaited belt.
-[Paul] To cover up the join.
A lovely way of doing it.
It looks very good.
There's definition there as well.
-I think that's a lovely texture.
-Mmm.
-[Paul] Lovely toasted.
-[Prue] Good bread.
[Paul] Not much of a hole.
Plaiting's not long enough
so they're tried to pull it around
and then it's blown up.
But the definition's there.
-[Prue] And the shine.
-[Paul] Yes.
It was okay.
Moving on to this one,
some thin bits and some fat bits.
There is good definition in this.
Quite a nice structure. Quite open.
-Nice texture.
-Mmm.
I think this one is under-proved.
Good indication of that is the tear there.
The bread's trying to force its way up,
and it's not quite there, so it's split.
Not much of a glaze on that.
Quite soft,
needed much longer in the oven.
Not a bad crumb.
I think that's delicious.
They all taste good, actually. Okay.
[Noel] The plaited wreaths
will now be ranked…
[imperceptible]
…from worst to first.
Tenth place is this one.
-That's me.
-Dylan.
-It's a little uneven and under-proved.
-Okay.
Ninth spot, we have this one.
John. Great definition.
-Where's the hole?
-Didn't stretch it enough.
[Noel] Christiaan is eighth.
Georgie, seventh.
Mike, sixth.
Gill, fifth.
Illiyin is fourth.
And Andy is third.
In second place, we have this one.
Sumayah, this is
a really nice loaf of bread.
-Good colour. Very good.
-Thanks.
-Which means…
-In first place, we have this one.
-Well done.
-[clapping]
[joyful classical music playing]
Nelly, you've plaited before.
The colour, the definition, the plaiting.
Very, very good.
It's very hard for me to take compliments
'cause all my life, I wasn't good enough.
And from Paul, the king of bread…
-Well done.
Thank you.
…was the biggest compliment I could have.
[Dylan] That went worse than I thought.
I'm not consistent, which is annoying.
With bread, normally I'm consistent.
I always knew Bread Week
wasn't gonna be my week.
I need to pull it out the bag tomorrow.
-[bees buzzing]
-[birds chirping]
[Alison] Just one final challenge
before the judges will name
Bread Week's Star Baker
and decide who will be
leaving the competition.
Can we just talk about the new Paul pat,
where you nearly get a handshake?
Georgie was over the moon.
-The new thing, the Paul pat.
-[Noel] It's a thing.
There's Postman Pat
and there's the Paul pat.
[all laugh]
They're talking about whether they'd get
a handshake or a pat.
[Alison] Yeah.
I was surprised
about the standard yesterday.
I was really pleasantly surprised.
The standard in the signature
was some of the best.
-[Noel] Ever?
-Ever.
The gochujang flavour inside
Dylan's rolls, that was ingenious.
But in technical, he came last.
It's very tight in the technical.
No one got it perfect.
I think Nelly was the closest to it.
She did a really good job.
[Prue] Exactly. That put her ahead.
[Paul] John might be feeling
a bit nervous.
He was second-to-last in the technical
and he was bottom for me
in the signature because of the air hole.
Usually, he does something that saves him.
He just has to not come last to stay.
You can't have a weak week,
and if you do, you could go.
And he's one of the stronger bakers.
Glad it's not the same for us
or we'd all be gone.
[all laugh]
Right, bakers. Time for your
Bread Week showstopper challenge.
The judges would love you to make
a bread cornucopia display.
Or a horn of plenty, as it's widely known.
Your horn must be beautifully shaped,
like Paul's.
[chuckles] And have at least
two different breads inside.
You have a staggering
four hours and 30 minutes.
[Alison] On your marks.
Get set.
B to the A to the K to the E, bake!
-[Georgie] Here we go.
-[Sumayah giggles]
[Noel] Traditionally, a cornucopia
is a horn-shaped basket
overflowing with fruits and vegetables.
But today, the judges are expecting
an abundance of breads.
We've got a massive production line
on the go today.
Everyone's like, bang, bang,
get these doughs done and proving.
[sighs]
[Noel] To produce their cornucopias,
the bakers will need to shape
their dough around formers.
Calling Mike! Too-doo-doo!
[Mike laughs]
Sorry. Say that again?
[both laughing]
Now, this is quite a tricky challenge
because they have to make the cornucopia
and it has to be fairly big.
Think of all those breads
they'll put inside.
But what's tricky is the whole bulk
of the horn itself
needs to be solid.
It can't collapse in the oven.
Inside the cornucopia, we want
at least two other kind of breads.
They can be sweet or savoury,
but we want something
really original and delicious,
and that shows us
their breadmaking skills.
I need to make sure I don't under-prove it
this time after yesterday's comments.
We've given them four and a half hours
to complete the cornucopia.
They'll need every single minute of that
to be able to produce what we want,
which is an amazing look,
fantastic flavours
and a real display of their workmanship.
-Good morning, Gill.
-Good morning.
[Prue] Gill, tell us
about your cornucopia.
So my cornucopia is a celebration
of my Devonshire holidays.
[Alison] Ooh.
[Noel] Gill's seaside-themed cornucopia
will contain the flavours
of her favourite summer holiday.
Onion and bacon plaits
to represent her bacon butty breakfasts,
beer bread mini loaves
and Devonshire splits
filled with strawberries and cream.
That's my holiday in a nutshell.
-Love it.
-Bacon, beer and cream cheese.
[Paul] Wow!
-[Alison laughs]
-Where have you been all my life?
[all laugh]
[Noel] Andy's also dedicating his bake
to a memorable holiday.
[Andy] The missus took me to New York
on my 40th birthday.
I had a fantastic time.
Best pizza I ever eaten
was, like, in New York.
Them flavours coming into it,
it's gonna be booming.
[Noel] Andy will be making
pizza-style buns,
cinnamon pretzels and focaccia muffins
all contained within
his brightly-painted horn.
You know what's amazing?
You should pat yourself on the back.
You started dead
and came third in the technical.
-I know.
-I was impressed by that.
Know what I've done there?
Given 'em all a chance.
[laughing] He's given them a chance.
Hello, John.
-Good morning.
-John.
So tell us about your cornucopia.
So my horn of plenty is celebrating Pride.
So the horn is in the Pride colours.
-I love it.
-Like the Pride flag.
[Noel] Filled with lemon and ginger buns
and cinnamon raisin bagels,
John is hoping to do himself proud today
with his rainbow cornucopia.
[Prue] That's a nice shape
of a cornucopia, isn't it?
[Paul] Yeah.
People have got very big horns
compared to mine.
-[chuckles]
-It's, erm--
It's not about the size, mate.
-It's what you do with it.
-Absolutely.
-Never had a problem before.
-[all laugh]
[Noel] Whilst John is hoping
pride doesn't come before a fall…
Paul likes my flavours.
He thinks the idea is great.
So it's about executing it.
…Sumayah is hoping
some very special recipes
will stand her in good stead.
So my cornucopia is inspired
by just recipes
passed down from like
friends and family and stuff.
It's a bit uncreative.
"What are you grateful for?"
"Er, friends and family." [laughs]
[Noel] Sumayah will be serving up cinnamon
and star anise Mexican concha bread
and a Middle Eastern fatayer bread
filled with feta, dill and parsley,
all contained within an
intricately decorated spiced cornucopia.
So this is my cornucopia dough,
and it's flavoured with, like,
sumac and paprika, cayenne.
-I'm wrapping this flat sheet of dough--
-The whole thing?
Yes, then I'll make a lattice
and cut it into strips.
Okay. That sounds interesting.
Okay. [laughs]
[Alison] Well done.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-[Sumayah] Thank you.
[Noel] Using formers ensures
the colossal cornucopias
hold their shape in the oven.
I'm gonna roll it up.
I think that's the best course of action.
I am wrapping my cornucopia like a mummy.
[Noel] However they approach
the design and construction…
[Dylan] I don't have braids or anything.
I'm doing black and white stripes.
…every join must be robust
if the bakers are to avoid collapse.
[Illiyin] You can see the bottom,
the gaps are too big?
I need to bring them together a bit more.
[Mike] Hoping the horn holds its shape.
The horn is going to be plaited,
and that's my decoration.
I love plaiting dough.
I love taking my sister to the Pony Club
and plaiting the tale of her pony.
[Noel] Mike's plaited horn will be filled
with herbed olive and cheddar twists,
cheese, tomato, basil and bacon twists
and rosemary fougasse.
Why did I choose to plait,
especially after we had
plaiting technical?
-See how fast Paul was plaiting?
-Oh, my God.
Watching him handle dough is…
It's quite a treat.
That's what this show is about.
I just wanna see Paul Hollywood
in gold wrestling pants, handling dough.
[laughs]
[Georgie] The horn itself,
it's quite a basic dough recipe
with rosemary.
It's massive.
It's a showstopper.
It certainly is.
[Alison] Georgie's super-sized cornucopia
will be filled with pumpkin
and pecan buns,
chocolate and hazelnut babka,
tahini swirls,
and decorated
with autumnal leaves and mice.
So have you got mice in your house?
-There's mice in the garden.
-Yeah.
-And there's rats in the roof.
-I love it.
In the countryside,
you can't get rid of them.
There's no way, so it's pointless.
-Might as well embrace them.
-Live with 'em.
My little friends. I love animals.
[Noel] Georgie isn't the only baker
paying tribute to her furry friends.
-Hello.
-Hi.
You've made Tim Burton's horn.
-Yeah.
-Love it.
-It's meant to be a cat toe.
-Have you got a cat?
I've got two cats, yeah.
-Have you?
-Yeah. Two cats.
One dog. She's new.
-I didn't want her, to be honest.
-[chuckles]
-It sounds harsh.
-She might be watching this.
[mimicking dog whimpering] Dylan!
Now I have her, I like her.
[mimicking dog] I heard what you said
on the baking show!
Inside the belly of Dylan's cat cornucopia
will sit amaretto crème brûlée doughnuts,
maple bacon cinnamon knots
and a country loaf,
accompanied by whipped bone marrow.
I'll tell you a secret now.
Earlier on, Paul said
your signature was ingenious.
-Really?
-Just saying.
-That's quite cool.
-[claps] Thought I'd give you a boost.
-Good luck.
-Cheers, Noel [laughs]
[Alison] As the super-sized
showstoppers hit the ovens…
Oh, please fit.
Let's just hope it doesn't melt off.
…the bakers' attention can
turn to the bounty of breads
that will fill their horns.
I've got, like, so many bakes to do now.
I really have got to push on.
[Gill] This is the bacon going into
the onion bread.
This is just my cinnamon bagel dough.
It smells delicious.
[Georgie] These are little pumpkins.
While I am finishing off these,
I'm starting off the next dough.
Here's the poppy seed. With sugar, orange,
and a little bit butter I gonna put now.
-That's a lot of poppy seeds.
-Yes.
And you'll love it, hopefully.
[Noel] Nelly is hoping to build
on her Bread Week success
with a potato and onion bread horn,
which will be overflowing
with poppy seed and orange samosas,
walnut wreaths
and sweet cream cheese buns.
How'd it feel to come first
in the technical?
-You cried, didn't you?
-Yeah.
-Do you cry quite a lot?
-No.
I won't cry,
but tomorrow, I'll go to a cave
and scream for an hour and half…
-[chuckles]
-…until all the bats fly out. [laughs]
When you see the bats in the sky,
it will form your name.
"Nelly, number one."
-Aw.
-What do you think about that?
You've got one in your hair actually.
Good luck.
[snickers]
-Illiyin, good morning.
-Good morning.
-How are you?
-Good.
Right, tell us all about your cornucopia.
The theme for mine is all about
family and coming together.
So each of the buns and the cornucopia
itself will be sort of braided.
It is about togetherness.
[Noel] Illiyin's plaited cornucopia
will be filled with feta,
parsley and harissa wreaths,
jalapeño and sun-dried tomato babka
and a halloumi, coriander,
and olive knotted bun.
-[Paul] Eat bread with halloumi often?
-Yeah.
If you ever try it at home again,
just do halloumi…
-Yeah.
-…and dried mint.
Should I have done that today?
I'm not saying you should've done that.
Next time, try it. It's delicious.
-Okay.
-Pretty good. Thank you.
-Thank you.
He's kind of given me
a bit of an idea. [chuckles]
Oh, maybe I could add
a little tiny bit of mint to that.
-[Paul] Christiaan, good morning.
-Hello. Good morning.
Christiaan, tell us
all about your cornucopia.
-What are you doing?
-So this is my orchid bun.
I've themed it around
one of my favourite things to do
on a spring afternoon,
which is going to the British countryside
and look at the wildflowers.
[Noel] Christiaan's
floral-themed cornucopia
will be filled with garlic
and stilton bread orchids
and rose-shaped sweet buns
filled with strawberry and cardamom jam.
I like the idea of the flavours.
It's about how it's gonna look.
-Yeah.
-It's about the decoration.
Sounds good. You sound confident.
Well… [laughs]
-We'll see.
-Good luck.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you, guys.
[birds chirping]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Woo--
Two hours and 15 minutes left.
"Woo-- Woo--"
[both laugh]
[Alison] With the cornucopias
taking up all the oven space…
[Nelly] Looking good. I'm happy.
…the bakers need to ensure
their other breads
are prepped and ready to hit the oven
as soon as the cornucopias come out.
[Georgie] I need to crack on here now.
[Sumayah] So this is the concha topping,
which is basically like a sweet biscuit.
And then when it bakes,
it should, like, melt and crack.
[Alison] But there's a problem
with John's bagels.
[John] They don't normally sink.
Normally, they float pretty well.
I make bagels all the time.
-And they've never sank, ever.
-[Alison] Hello, darling.
I'm not having a good day.
My bagels aren't rising.
So, I make bagels all the time.
I could absolutely cry for you
because you smashed it.
-I know.
-Is it just that it's Bread Week?
It's just this week.
-Don't get upset.
-Don't make me cry.
Don't get upset, please.
Don't get upset, babe.
Don't, don't get upset.
You all right?
It's just bread. Mwah!
-It's just bread.
-Yeah.
-Thanks.
-I just want to hug you.
-Let's have a minute.
-Yeah.
[Mike] Oh, John.
Aw, that breaks my heart now.
[dramatic music playing]
[John sighing heavily]
[Alison] Can I say something? Come here.
-When I did Strictly as a dancer.
-Yeah.
-And I knew I was going.
I knew in my heart, I was going,
but Aljaž looked at me and went,
"She can still fall over."
[both laugh]
So I'm looking at you now and going…
Someone could still burn it.
Hold your head up high.
-I am
-Bake, enjoy yourself, have a laugh,
and someone could still fall over.
[Andy] No.
It's come off. [groans]
First time it's done it.
Done it four times, never had a problem.
How long's left?
How long have we got to persevere for?
Quite brief.
Bakers, you've got one hour left.
[Noel] As the horns come out,
it's the moment of truth for the bakers.
[John] Yeah, happy with that.
Back on track.
My squiggles have smushed a little bit.
But you're in the hands
of the baking gods for those.
[Noel] Whilst most have survived
the oven unscathed…
Phew.
Yeah, I'm happy with it.
Now I just need to let it cool.
…Andy's has structural issues.
[Andy] Oh, shoot.
What I didn't want to happen
has happened. [grunts]
[Noel] With at least two different breads
needed to fill their cornucopias…
They are not gonna rise properly.
…the bakers now face a race against time
to prepare their bounty.
[Georgie] They go in for ten minutes
moving on to the babkas next.
Okay, right. [exhales]
[John] This is a lemon and ginger bun.
My hand is normally pretty steady.
But today, could be all over the place.
Bit like, bit like the day.
[Dylan] I'm doing amaretto
crème brûlée doughnuts.
So they'll have a crispy caramel on top.
[Noel] Is it really hot?
Well, that is probably
about 150 degrees Celsius.
Okay. Shall I keep my distance?
This is all I've got, Dylan.
This is all I've got.
[laughs]
These cheek bones.
If this goes, I've got nothing.
[crows cawing]
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
-[timer beeping]
-[Andy] Need to hurry up.
Oh, tahini out.
[Dylan] A few knots are broken,
which is annoying.
Are you ready
to see these terrible bagels?
Oh, my God, they're just a disaster.
They're a bit uneven,
but I know they're going to taste fine.
[Andy] Dunking the pretzels
in cinnamon and sugar.
[Dylan] That's whipped bone marrow.
Oh, that looks so good, doesn't it?
Yeah. It is meaty butter.
I'm gonna fill the pumpkins
with a crème pât.
That's lemon and ginger syrup
just to give it a glaze.
[Christiaan] This is my orchid bun.
[Andy] Just gotta chill out, man.
Chill out and it'll be all right,
I know it.
These are my little dinosaur spikes
for the Jurassic coastline.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
I'm just painting some bronze
onto some leaves.
Everything's out of the oven,
which is good.
Now I just need to start putting stuff in.
Fudge!
I'd love to shove 'em in the bin
rather than at the back.
Tissue, tissue, tissues.
Okay, bakers, your time is up.
-Thank God!
-Please step away from your bakes.
-[whoops]
-[Georgie] Well done, everyone.
Yeah, it's all right. It's all right.
It's not awful.
[sobs, sniffles]
[birds chirping]
[Noel] It's judgment time
for the bakers' cornucopias.
Nelly, would you like to bring up
your showstopper, please?
Yes.
[tense music playing]
Straight off,
I think the cornucopia's amazing.
-The detail's incredible.
-Thank you.
And you've got a continuity
in colour as well. They look great.
-Yeah, looks lovely.
-Let's have a look at one of these.
[Nelly] Yeah,
that's a poppy seed orange filling.
-My God, that is such a--
-Wow.
[Paul] There's definitely
poppy seed in this.
-That's delicious.
-[Prue] Delicious.
The bread texture complements that
so well as well. That's the key for me.
-[Prue] It's nice and soft.
-Mm.
This is my favourite. This is sweet cheese
with cinnamon and lemon.
And on top is walnuts
and a butter crumble.
-I like that.
-Mm.
The zest lifts it. That is very good.
-I might take a bit of this…
-[Prue] Oh, that's the savoury one?
Yeah, onion and potato.
Spectacular.
[Prue] I think you've done
a really good job.
Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] I love the cornucopia.
It's a classic shape.
It's so big and the colour's amazing.
And I love what's pouring out
the inside as well.
[Prue] Just fantastic.
[Paul] Let's try… This is the hazelnut?
Hazelnut and chocolate, yeah.
I love that. Dough's nice and soft.
It's really sweet and chocolatey.
It's luxurious, isn't it?
Great job with that.
Let's have a look at these.
I've got pumpkin rolls
filled with a crème pât.
The spice levels
in the pumpkin are perfect.
It needed more proving.
That would've opened it up.
It's a bit stodgy inside.
-Yeah.
-But the flavour is beautiful.
-Great ideas and well executed.
-[Prue] Well done, Georgie.
[tense classical music playing]
[Paul] I love the cornucopia.
It's a real treat on the eyes.
Let's try the kalamata first, shall we?
Mm, I love it.
That's a good amount of olives.
It's nice and sharp.
And then lastly, I've got fougasse
with rosemary from my garden.
Rosemary level is perfect,
the shape is very good.
The texture is not good.
-Okay.
-For a fougasse.
-Yeah.
-But I do like the flavour.
[tense classical music playing]
I love the breads pouring out.
Looks good. Let's look at one of these.
They're filled with coriander,
spring onion, touch of mint,
haloumi and kalamata olives.
-That's delicious.
-Thank you.
-What is this, tomato?
-[Illiyin] Yes. It's--
Tomato and jalapeño?
-Tomato and jalapeño.
-That's delicious.
-It's got a nice kick to it as well.
-You've done really well, Illiyin.
[Paul] I think you've done
a really nice job there.
It's neat as a pin,
but let's see what they taste like.
-Start with this. This is?
-Onion and bacon.
-I like that.
-Mm.
It's quite mild flavoured,
but it's delicious.
-Great flavour, more proving needed.
-Okay.
This is my Devonshire splits
with strawberry jam and cream.
That is gonna be delicious.
[laughs]
-It's a nice Devonshire split.
-[Prue] Very good.
-I think you kept it pretty safe.
-Okay.
But it's worked, that's the thing.
Everything you said happened.
-So well done.
-Thank you.
[classical music playing]
[Paul] I think the little rose flowers
look good.
I worry a little bit about these.
-[laughter]
-I don't know what that is.
-[laughs]
-[Prue] It's an orchid.
That's not an orchid!
I know what an orchid looks like
and that's not an orchid.
[laughter]
So it's, erm,
caramelised garlic and stilton.
Where's the stilton?
[Prue] It's disappeared.
There's nothing there. Let's try this.
The other buns, that's sugarbread
and then a strawberry and cardamom jam.
[whimsical classical music playing]
It's delicious,
but that's because it's mostly filling.
No dough.
I really like the flavour.
-Okay.
-I really like it.
[classical music playing]
[Prue] I think it looks spectacular.
I love the colours.
[Sumayah] So these are the conchas
flavoured with cinnamon and star anise.
[classical music playing]
-It's a bit boring.
-Mm-hmm.
It needs a lot more
going on in there. Right.
So the cornucopia is a spiced white dough
with paprika, cayenne, rosemary
and a garlic butter on top.
Wow, paprika's worked in that, hasn't it?
I like that.
-Thank you.
-That's really nice.
-Spicy bread.
-Wow, that's great.
[classical music playing]
I hope it tastes as good as it looks.
-It's exquisite. It's really neatly done.
-Okay.
The doughnuts have an amaretto crème pât
and like a sugar coating on top.
Nothing like any doughnut I've ever had,
but it's lovely.
-[chuckles]
-[Paul] Very good.
[Prue] I love the knot.
It looks like something special.
-It looks expensive.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's quite indulgent, isn't it?
-Oh, it's lovely.
It's moist, soft,
you've got great cinnamon layers.
Really nice. I like that.
-Okay, let's look at this.
-Then we dip it in that?
-[Dylan] Yeah.
-[Paul] Nice.
I've never heard of whipping bone marrow.
And I love bone marrow.
Very well done,
that's a lovely little loaf, that.
Crispiness is just right.
Smells lovely as well. Very clever.
You're a decent bread baker, Dylan.
-Cheers.
-[Prue chuckles] Sure are.
[classical music playing]
[Prue] I think the cornucopia
could've been a bit bigger.
There's no possibility any of those things
could've got in there
to spill out in that generous way.
[Paul] The pretzels are not
what I'd think of as a pretzel.
They need to be much thinner
and the shaping needs to be sharper,
but you've managed to achieve
probably a cinnamon bun.
-If you'd said, "That's a cinnamon bun".
-It's a cinnamon bun.
-[Paul] Right, okay.
-[laughter]
We've got a pizza,
which is a Detroit-style pizza.
Once you go past the filling
and you hit the bread, it's a bit bland.
-Right.
-I would've had that half that thickness.
Oh, right, okay. Yeah.
Then you've got a focaccia
with rosemary and olives.
-It's not a focaccia, is it?
-[Paul] No.
Andy, I don't have too much of a problem
with the bread.
I think they're all acceptable.
But the problem is,
they're called pizza and focaccia…
-Of course.
-…so you have something in your head
-about what you're expecting.
-What you're expecting to have.
However, the cinnamon roll is delicious.
-Thank you.
-Really unusual, and I like that.
A pretzel it isn't.
-No.
-But cinnamon bun it is.
-It's delicious.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[classical music playing]
-[Prue] Well, it looks fantastic.
-Thanks.
Love the shine, love the colour.
-The coloured buns look a bit boring.
-[John] Yeah.
-And as for the bagel…
-They sunk in the water.
-Sounds like you over-proved them.
-Okay.
When they hit the hot water,
it forces the air and it drops.
By the time they're in the oven,
they're flat.
[John] Yeah.
This is a lemon and ginger bun.
-Quite tight.
-Yeah.
There's not enough lemon in there.
A lot more proving.
And then, more interesting shape
would've been nice.
No, absolutely.
Don't. I wouldn't even bother.
[laughs] Use it as a Frisbee.
You can't eat that.
Overall, I think you've made
an impressive centrepiece.
[John] Mm-hmm.
-Pity about the bagels.
-Yeah. I totally agree.
It went as to be expected.
I was happy with how it looked.
But I knew coming into today
it wasn't gonna be my day.
One person's gotta go home
and I just hope it ain't me.
And I'll be totally honest.
I love everyone, but at the end
of the day, I'm here for me.
I just hope I've done enough.
It went way better
than I thought it would.
So that was nice.
Well done, geez.
When Paul said I was a decent bread baker,
that is wicked, that is really nice, yeah.
[Noel] Wow, what a week.
Over the three challenges,
as a Bread Week, one of the best.
This lot are just very talented bakers.
John and Andy both struggled
during the showstopper.
[Paul] Mmm.
[Noel] Both of them knew
that they'd made mistakes.
Andy's focaccia just wasn't open enough
to be a proper focaccia.
-There wasn't enough oil in it.
-Not oily enough.
And there wasn't enough flavour.
[Prue] John, those buns of his,
were a bit feeble in flavour.
Just a round roll with some colours on.
And it just…
You could've done so much more with that.
So who's vying for the top spot
at the moment, then?
-Nelly? Yeah.
-Nelly, for sure.
-Nelly's on a different level.
-[Paul] Nelly did a great job.
Her design and flavours were spectacular.
-Georgie is in and around.
-They could be Star Baker?
Yeah, if you're gonna throw her hat
in the ring for Star Baker,
-which I think you can…
-[Prue] Absolutely.
…I'm gonna throw Dylan's in there.
Dylan's showstopper was so elegant.
Does he remind you of you.
Was you making a roll like that at 20?
-No, I was not. No.
-Was you not?
What age did you get
to do a roll like that?
-About 56.
-[laughter]
I'd say you've still got that to come.
[tense classical music playing]
Well done, bakers,
for getting through Bread Week
under the scrutiny of Mr Paul Hollywood.
You did so, so well.
I'm really excited
'cause I get the good news
of announcing this week's Star Baker.
This week's Star Baker is…
[suspenseful music playing]
Dylan.
[whooping]
[Noel] Amazing.
That means I've got the horrible news
of announcing which one of you
will be leaving us.
And the person who is leaving us
this week is…
[suspenseful music playing]
John.
It's fine. It was expected.
It was just a bad week, this week.
-Sorry, mate.
-Thanks so much, Paul.
-It wasn't your week.
-No, it just really wasn't.
It's just how it is.
I've just had a bad week.
And because everyone is so talented,
you drop the ball,
then it's your time to go.
Literally, to be the first Star Baker
of this season.
Then I had a really good week
last week as well.
So you know what?
The tears are tears of pride.
Yeah.
[Paul] Well done, Dylan.
Well done. More of that'd be good.
Cheers. [chuckles]
The first thing that went through my head,
"I can't believe I'm here."
It's just crazy.
I'm really happy I won it on Bread Week
just 'cause I really like bread.
And just 'cause Paul really knows bread.
He's amazed me, actually.
The standard that he took it to
in the last couple of days is exceptional.
-Well done, mate.
-Cheers.
[Paul] Bread Week's been amazing.
The best Bread Week
I've been involved with.
I will remember this week in particular
for a long time.
Don't know what all the panic
was about, really. [laughs]
Flippin' hell!
Brush myself down now, sort my life out,
and get on to Caramel Week.
Week four. Who would've thought?
[closing theme music playing]